in the last video we figured out what is
the present value of these three
different payment timing choices if we
had a five percent risk-free rate and if
these payments were risk-free you can
instead of coming from you can almost
view of that this is some type of
government program where they're asking
you to choose which of these three
payment streams for the government do
you want and so we'll use the same rate
that the government would pay you is if
you lent them money and that's given by
the the Treasury rate and in the first
case we assumed a 5% Treasury rate and
if you watch the first present value
video I think you understand why
compounding going forward is the same
thing as discounting that rate by going
backwards right if you want to know how
much $100 is in a year from now you
multiply that times 1 plus the disc one
plus the the interest rate right so if
it's 5% you multiply that times 1.05 if
you're taking $110 and going a year back
you would divided by 1.05 so it's just
the same operation you're just going
forward or back forward is
multiplication backwards is division but
anyway the the result that we got in the
last video is that the present value let
me do this in a different color and I'll
introduce my notation the present value
if we assume a 5% rate for all for
dependent no matter how long the how far
away the money is given to you and and
you'll see what I mean
because I'll change that assumption in a
second but if we assume that the that
the risk-free rate is 5% then the
present value of the hundred dollars
today well that was just $100 one
hundred and ten dollars in two years we
got that by doing 110 divided by 1.05
squared right you divided by 1.05 there
and then you get divided by 1.05 again
and then you get we got ninety nine
dollars and seventy seven cents
ninety-nine point seven seven I don't
want to run out of too much space I
could have probably done this whole
thing a little bit bigger and then
choice number three how did we get that
well we said let me do that in a
different color that was the present
value of the twenty
today plus $50 in one year
divided by that discounted to the
present day so divided by 1.05 plus $35
divided by 1.05 squared and we had
gotten 99 dollars and 36 cents and
that's that's the that's what that
should be worth to you today if you
assume that these payments are risk-free
and you use a 5% discount rate fair
enough and based on these calculations
choice number one was the best choice
number two a second best choice number
three was third best fair enough now
what happens and you might want to after
I posed the question you might want to
think about it before I show you the
answer what happens if I don't assume a
five percent discount rate what happens
if I assume PV let's assume a two
percent discount rate this is just my
notation what is the present value of
these if I assume a two percent
risk-free rate or two percent discount
rate
well the hundred dollars I'm getting
that today so that's still worth $100
you can even do that as one hundred let
me do that in a more vibrant color as
100 divided by one point O two to the
zeroth power because we're getting it
today but that's just one point O two
divided by one which is just a hundred
dollars right a hundred dollars today
what's the present value it's a hundred
dollars now what's the 105 doll what's
110 dollars two years out going to be
worth so this is interesting when the
interest rate goes down right went from
five percent to two percent I'm going to
be dividing by a smaller number right
1.02 squared is a smaller number than
1.05 squared so the present value of
this payment should go up interesting
this is something to keep in mind for
later when we start thinking about bonds
when you lower the interest rate the
present value of this future payment
goes up and it just falls out of the
math you're discounting by a smaller
number now let's figure out what that is
so if I take $110 and I divide it by one
point O two squared right just got it
twice I get one hundred five dollars and
seventy two cents
105 and 72 cents right oh and how did I
get that that was equal to I'm doing it
in Reverse here but that was equal to
110 divided by 1.0 two squared and our
intuition was correct right just by the
interest rate going from five percent to
two percent the present value of this
payment two years out right it's in year
three but it's two years out actually I
should real able this I should call this
now the present I should call this year
one I was calling this year two one year
out but I think that makes it confusing
I call this year two so this is now so
you could call this year zero right this
is year one and this is year two anyway
the present value of this is 105 it
increased by six dollars just by the
discount rate going down by three
percent fascinating now let's see what
happens to choice number three choice
number three the $20 today the $20 now
well that's just worth $20 it's present
values 20 plus 50 divided by 1.0 to plus
35 divided by 1.0 to squared
see what this ends up 20 plus 50 divided
by 1.02 plus 35 divided by 1.0 two
squared one hundred and two dollars and
sixty six cents so this is equal to 102
dollars and sixty six cents now there's
a couple of really interesting things
and this is a really good time to kind
of let it all sink in all of a sudden we
lower the interest rate and now choice
number two is the best followed by
choice number three
followed by choice number one so it
almost you know choice number one was
the best when we had a 5% discount rate
not a 2% discount rate choice number two
is all of a sudden the best and there's
something else interesting here choice
number two improved by a lot more when
we lower the interest rate than choice
number
three did write this its present value
went from ninety nine dollars and
seventy seven cents to one hundred five
dollars and seventy set so it's almost
six dollars while here it only improved
by less than three dollars right so why
is that well when you lower the interest
rate right the terms that are using that
discount rate the most benefit the most
so that all of this payment was two
years out right so it benefited the most
by decreasing the the the discount rate
right the one point oh two squared it
changed this value the most these
payments are spread out right only some
of its payment is two years out then
some of its payment is one year out and
that's going to benefit less right and
then some of its payment is today so it
will benefit because you are discounting
some of the cash payments but it's going
to benefit by less anyway I'll leave you
there in this video and in the next
video we're going to see what happens
when we have different discount rates
for different amounts of time see in the
next video